[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on september the 16th
my name is freddie gray i'm the deputy
editor of the spectator and i'll be your
host today
on the show we are going to be talking
about boris's big reshuffle
what does the new cabinet tell us about
the state of this administration i'll be
joined by james forsyth and katie balls
we will then move on to the question of
who is afraid of higher wages
that'll be a discussion of our cover
piece with matthew lynn
and andrew adonis and after that we're
going to talk to michaela wrong about
rwanda
is paul kagame the darling of the west
that we once thought he was
we'll then move on to extinction
rebellion and ask if their tactics
are helpful
or justified
and finally we'll talk about nfts what
the hell is a non-fundable token and why
not subscribe to the spectator magazine
as well
you can get 10 weeks of the magazine
delivered to your door plus a bottle of
pims worth 25 pounds for just 10 pounds
to take up that delicious deal just go
to www.spectator.co.ukforward
tv offer and you better hurry up because
it's only available while stocks last
first up you may or may not have noticed
that britain is experiencing a labor
shortage there is for instance a lack of
truck drivers available
and a concomitant shortage of produce on
supermarket shelves
is it all bad news though i'm joined by
matthew lin who wrote the spectator's
cover piece this week which is entitled
payday who's afraid of higher wages as
well as andrew adonis the remain
campaigner and the chairman of european
movement uk
matthew in your cover piece you argue
that despite the obvious disruption it
is a good thing that the labor market is
changing can you run us through your
argument
yeah absolutely i mean you know
obviously you know in the uk at the
moment we're seeing
you know quite severe labor shortages in
a way that we haven't for for a heck of
a long time you're seeing you know
critical shortages of truck drivers
hospitality staff
and you're seeing you know some
shortages in
in the shop some restaurants closing at
lunch time
but you're also saying and this is the
interesting bit is you're also seeing
rapidly rising wages you know we're
seeing um cost of coffee for example you
know gave a five percent pay rise to
what it's stuff i think five percent
it's not going to be enough you know
you're gonna get a costume in a couple
of weeks time and there won't be anyone
off the milk for you uh we're seeing
truck drivers getting 20 to 30 percent
uh pay rises um so you know i think the
overall picture is is you know
uh fascinating we haven't been in the
situation in the uk uh for a long time
uh but we are seeing you know we're
definitely seeing disruption and that
and that's difficult but the free market
works redisruption you know it has price
signals um it has shocks uh most of the
time those are fairly minor uh but
sometimes they're quite extreme when you
know when you get extreme changes in
market conditions you get quite extreme
price movements and we're seeing that at
the moment in the labor market but
you've got to keep sight of the big
picture i think you'll get through the
disruption and we'll take three to six
months or so at the end of it you'll see
you know very significant rises in blue
collar wages that's not great for
everyone you know it's not great if
you're running a big company uh or even
if you own a small company but if you're
you know if you're one of the blue
collar workers who haven't had a great
deal in the last 20 years um you know
it's hard to see what's exactly so
terrible about a 20 to 30 pay raise
andrew uh matthew suggests that brexit
is just a small part of the picture here
uh do you think he's guilty of painting
a a rose-tinted picture
uh of the brexit situation and britain's
economy
well he invited us to look at the big
picture and
the big picture that he's painting has
some elements i quite like i mean i love
the idea that the spectator's not going
to come up campaigning for much higher
wages i assume a much higher minimum
wage he talked to 20 to 30 percent
higher wages for blue-collar workers
well most union negotiators wouldn't
think that that was uh immediately
attainable so if we're now having a
realignment that has a new center being
created where people on the right who
tended to argue in favor of much lower
wages for manual blue collar
traditionally unskilled workers there
should be much higher wages for them
then i'm all in favor of that and that's
great and that's alone worth my coming
into the spectator to debate with
matthew on the issue of brexit though of
course you can have much higher wages
and you didn't need to brexit the issue
on brexit is whether you're going to
cause this massive disruption in being
able to recruit anybody to fill these
jobs at the moment because whatever your
view about the medium term and the
median term i'd love to see
higher wages and a new equilibrium of
high wage and higher skill that's great
but the short term we're we're facing at
the moment which you can never discount
because the short terms have an uncanny
habit of going into medium and long
terms as well he says a few months how
does he know it's going to be a few
months before we can start dealing with
this hundred thousand backlog of hgv
drivers that's a hundred thousand out of
six hundred 000 that we had
before the pandemic so dealing with
those short-term issues is also
important and again regardless of your
view on brexit pragmatism is required
here what should obviously have happened
was the issuing of a large number of
short-term visas
to enable eu workers who were previously
doing these jobs to do so on the same
terms and to encourage them to do so and
the failure of the government to do that
is straightforward ideological
negligence it was ideological because
they weren't prepared to do it because
of brexit and it was negligent because
as a result we've got empty supermarket
shelves which
massively impede the operation of the
market
so there are some complicated things
going on here but the big thing about
matthew's article i think is absolutely
fantastic which is that the spectator
and people who traditionally been on the
right and wanted more inequality in
society like matthew are now
dramatically in favor of much higher
wages for blue-collar workers and
low-paid workers because they think
somehow that's going to be a brexit
dividend what i want is to continue
trading
profitably with our european partners
not put all these impediments in place
but also have the higher wages and i
think that's absolutely possible i'm not
sure the spectators always campaign for
inequality i'm not sure that's quite
fair but i mean what a point matthew
makes is this is what people voted for
when they voted for brexit do you think
that's a fair point people were fed up
of
an economic system that did not see
their wages grow you say that you can
have
wage growth without brexit but the fact
is there hasn't been
wage growth at the bottom end of the
economy for a very long time well i
think there's a much much bigger problem
underlying the uh the the vote for
brexit in
in in particular the midlands and the
north which was the lack of a proper
economic plan for any sustainable
long-term jobs in many of the
communities that voted heavily for
brexit and a big challenge for us all
and it is is how you put that right what
is the economic future
of all those east coast towns and many
of the industrial centers that have been
de-industrialized over the last 30 years
now brexit to my mind is almost
irrelevant to that because brexit isn't
going to produce any new industries or
jobs in these areas
and we've now got to concentrate really
really seriously as a country and what
we do do about it and i suspect that
process isn't even going to start until
we've worked
brexit through the system and it's
probably created even larger levels of
unemployment in its wake matthew i'll
let you reply to what 100 you said there
made so many attacks there it's a little
it was a little hard to keep up with
them i mean just a couple of points on
that i think you know it's unfair to say
that people on the center right have
campaigned um
in favor of inequality
uh or lower wages i think i think that's
just just just just ridiculous you know
people are people probably on the center
right or the free market like we believe
in market outcomes but we certainly
think it's great when market outcomes
produce as they should if you allow them
to operate properly and in the correct
framework um higher wages and and
hopefully lower inequality i think just
on the brexit point i mean i did i don't
think we should make this particularly
about brexit i think one of the problems
in this country is obviously you know
we're still
we're still tending to wage that battle
everyone's still arguing about it and
we're still in the aftermath of it so we
kind of look at everything and say well
that's that's good because it's brexit
that's bad because of brexit i think i i
tried to reflect this in the piece you
know this is a global phenomenon brexit
has definitely been a little part of the
story
in the uk
but we're seeing you know big shortages
of workers in germany last time i
checked germany hadn't left the eu
we're seeing big shortages of workers um
in
the united states the mexicans aren't
going to the united states with anything
like the same numbers not illegally i
can't put that in that's that's kind of
a caveat but legally they're not getting
anything like the same numbers last time
i checked the united states hadn't left
the eu possibly never even joined it uh
so you know this is actually a global a
global phenomena and you know we can dig
into some of the reasons for that i
don't think we should especially think
that it's a consequence of brexit it's
kind of triggered it and sparked it and
accelerated a little bit i will concede
that but there's a lot more there's a
lot more going there and i think on
andrew's point you know if i if people
like andrew and i know a lot of the
employers uh are arguing this that if we
suddenly granted a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand extra visas to anyone
from hungary or poland or the ukraine
who wanted to come over here and drive a
truck or clean a hotel room actually two
points on that i i don't think they'd
come
because they're not going to germany in
the same in in the same numbers that
they were and within the eu germany was
the other country which people moved to
in big numbers as well as the uk uh and
the germans are critically sure of
workers as well at the head of the
federal employment agency was saying
recently they needed six hundred
thousand more people uh to fill all the
vacancies they have so i don't think
they'd necessarily come and i also think
you know even if they did it would be a
mistake that we've actually started this
rebalancing process which is going to
lead to a a restructuring of the uk
economy uh and it's going to lead to
higher blue collar wages and we've got
you know we we're seeing the disruption
it like any kind of restructuring you
know it is going to be a little bit of
pain involved there's going to be a
little bit of disruption involved
just as when the oil market changes or
you know the corn market changes or the
copper or the copper market changes um
but once you get through that you'll
actually be in a better place so i think
the worst thing we could do is kind of
panic uh you know unless things are
absolutely critical i know there are a
few shortages as long as everything's
roughly working okay we shouldn't panic
we should let the process um
uh pla play itself out i think we'll end
up in a better place so we'll actually
end up with with higher blue collar
wages i believe and and a slightly more
equal leveled up society which i know i
know andrea thinks nobody on the center
right could ever be in favor of that uh
but actually you know actually actually
they are and i think that that will be
an improvement the the great danger i
suppose of rising wages well we all
acknowledge it's a good thing for wages
to go up even at the spectator we
acknowledge that
is inflation of course which we saw
yesterday i think 3.2 percent is the cpi
uh rate in august i i mean it is is the
danger here that we will inflate away
any gains uh to wages at the lower end
of the economy thus actually spoiling
any positive effects that that might
have
inflation you know when you have rapidly
rising wages inflation is definitely a
danger but i mean i'm going to make two
points on that it's a it depends on your
pricing power as a company you know if
you're a company and you've suddenly got
to pay 20 more to your staff
um you have the option of increasing
prices and some people will do that i
mean i've known it you know in london
i've noticed you know the price of my
cup of coffee is going up and cough the
coffee industry it was very dependent
upon eu migrant work workforce as we
know and you know some people are going
to put the price of a cup up 20 30 p
and you're probably about to just have
to take that in the chin so you'll see a
little bit of inflation but other other
companies don't have any pricing power
so for example i saw ocado this week was
talking about a 5 million hit to profit
because it has to pay its drivers more i
don't think academic can put its prices
up i think you know if they do amazon
will eat their lunch um in a moment if
you're competing with amazon you can't
put your prices up because they'll just
come and destroy you in an instant so
they're going to have to they would say
they're going to have to take that as a
hate on profit so that means you know
there's more money for van drivers for
ricardo and less money for cardo
shareholders and you know andrew's got
to jump on me and say this is unusual
but i think that's okay that's just the
market rebalancing shareholders in a
card and the chief executive has a
little bit less money
and the van drivers have a bit more
money that's okay you know that's just
the market working working itself out so
i think we might see some inflation just
one more point on that you know
we are going to see a little bit of
inflation we saw 3.2 percent um this
week that might it might even spike up
to four
but if we're seeing wages i think on the
latest ons figures we're eight percent
across the board uh and we're seeing
definitely in you know things like
amongst lorry drivers uh up to thirty
percent um uh pay rises look if you get
a 30 pay rise for driving a lorry and
prices are up four percent you still
came out ahead didn't you um so some
people are losing um and uh possibly
people at the top of the top of the pay
scale are going to lose a little bit
but that's just part of the rebalancing
andrew i'll let you have the last word
uh are you guilty of having a myopic
focus on brexit
well i i didn't start with brexit and
i'm not going to finish with it either i
think it's just wonderful that the
spectators now uh miraculously in favor
of of much higher blue-collar wages i
think we should just celebrate this i
hope all the people watching spectator
tv will uh uh will note that now
can you point can you point to any can
you point to any uh
i think that's fantastic so i just want
to applaud the spectator for that
however uh
it is complacent to say that we
shouldn't worry about empty supermarket
shelves massive problems in supply
chains all of those things which
actually are important to the effective
operation of markets which i thought the
spectator also stood for because this
huge disruption we've got is because a
whole basis of trade has been disrupted
and we've contracted our markets in many
ways because we've put big impediments
to trade between different parts of our
markets and when matthew said that
he didn't think we should offer more
short-term visas to
uh people from other european countries
uh he he wasn't clear on his reason for
it it indeed he was contradictory he
said that they wouldn't want to take
them up well if they didn't wouldn't
want to take them up then obviously it's
not going to do any harm but he said ah
even if they did want to take them up it
would be bad now both of those can't be
true and the right thing to do surely is
not to suffer massive disruption not to
have empty supermarket shelves to see
that it is possible for people to take
up uh short-term visas and short-term
work so we can deal with that
but also join the spectator campaign for
higher minimum wage higher blue collar
uh uh wages a stronger trade union
movement less uh profits going into
dividends and high executive pay which i
also took matthew to be saying all these
are great causes and i welcomed the
spectator to them many years after many
of us started campaigning for them thank
you matthew and thank you andrew now
onto politics boris's big reshuffle
happened yesterday and i'm going to be
talking now to james and katie about
what that says about the state of his
premiership katie you were as usual
ahead of the curve on this with your
various bits of writing this week what's
going on so there have been constant
rumors of a reshuffle in recent weeks a
lot of speculation last week um but
ministers have been uh working on the
assumption that it would be on wednesday
uh this week and that's what came to
pass
and i think in terms of the changes i
think it was a bolder reshuffle than
many expected in westminster um i think
the fact that boris johnson chose to
demote his foreign secretary dominic
garav who surprisingly or perhaps
unsurprisingly did not want to be
demoted uh was showed that this was
quite a wide-ranging reshuffle um to
move a great office of state and i think
also the decision to not just move gavin
williamson as education secretary which
many people thought he would do
but to just remove them from the cabinet
entirely was interesting because there
had been a sense that boris johnson
would resist this um because he'd be
worried about putting someone like gavin
williams on the back benches former
chief whip somebody could organize and
cause some trouble and actually boris
johnson doesn't seem very worried at all
about upsetting people
james there's been quite a
growing impression that um
boris johnson isn't really in charge of
his administration that things aren't
under control was this an attempt to to
flex a bit of prime ministerial muscle
yeah i think this reshuffle was
sufficiently brutal but it will stop the
talk of drift that had been gathering
since tory mps returned to westminster
about 10 days ago i also think it's a
reshuffle that demonstrates kind of
prime ministerial patronage for example
nadine doris you know he was sitting in
the front row that day when he pulled
out of a tour leadership race in 2016
was sitting next to him in the house of
commons when he made his resignation
statement as foreign secretary two years
later she becomes secretary of state for
culture i think it's fair to say that
it's haunting any any other recent prime
minister who would have put her in the
cabinet but what boris johnson is saying
is you know this is my government and
i'm going to appoint people who i see as
loyal to me now i think the irony in
this is but perhaps the most interesting
appointment is that of michael gove the
man who caused boris johnson to have to
put out in 2016
because he has been put in charge of the
government's leveling up agenda and i
think the significance of that is that
you know post-brexit with covert
increasingly looking like it is receding
that it's becoming a kind of rear-view
mirror problem the government needs uh
as i say in the magazine this week it
needs a new purpose and a new mission
the most obvious candidate for that is
leveling up but up to now leveling up
has been quite an ill-defined quite a
vague term and i think the question is
whether michael gove can put meat on the
bone and give the government a clearer
sense of direction on this front
i wanted to ask you about that james
actually because it's it's interesting
the relationship between gove and
boris jones on many levels but he seems
now to be filling uh possibly a kind of
boris johnson shaped vacuum inside the
administration
is he is he actually the most powerful
person in the country now i don't use
the most powerful person in the country
because he yeah he serves at the
pleasure of boris johnson i think you
see
and i think that that that is the
limitation i think what you see is a
consistent pattern where despite what
the the water under the bridge between
them when it comes to various tricky
problems boris johnson likes to throw
the more ball to michael gove and say
solve them now these are often hospital
boxes like the hospital party gave him a
cabinet this week when he basically put
michael gove in charge of making sure
that christmas was not disrupted by all
the supply chain issues that are going
on at the moment because of a shortage
of of lorry drivers and the like the
things that matthew lynn touched on on
in his cover piece so i think what you
see essentially is boris johnson using
michael gove to solve some of the most
difficult problems facing him but it but
it's definitely boris johnson saying to
my grave go and fix that very difficult
problem if you can
katie what what exactly happened with
dominic robb who was replaced as foreign
secretary by liz trust
well it depends who you speak to um i
don't think dominic rob uh particularly
enjoyed the reshuffle you had a
situation where he was moved to justice
um but it didn't happen very quickly in
fact there had to be a negotiation
taking place because dominic rav did not
want to be moved from the foreign office
now this is in part because of the uh
the events leading up to this reshuffle
which means that dominic grav has been
heavily criticized for his response to
the chaos in afghanistan um the
evacuation of uh brits there of afghans
who should have been eligible to come
here a lot of that blame has gone on
dominic raab there's been a briefing war
between the home office the ministry of
defense and the foreign office but
dominic rob partly because he was on
holiday for uh a part of this um has
come out the worst and therefore i think
where the uh number 10 could potentially
have sold his move as him trying
pastures new it looks um like an emotion
and
effectively is one and it's very hard to
fit a gloss on it now dominic grav i
think tried to negotiate it to make it
less embarrassing and that's why he has
gone from first secretary of state to
deputy prime minister the roles are
pretty much the same and particularly
it's a more formal title i think it is
supposed to give him some cover but
obviously the the joke amongst tory mps
at the moment is that he hasn't
effectively done angela rainer um uh
this is uh kistama's deputy leader who
when she didn't like what happened in
the shadow cabinet reshuffle amassed
lots of titles to try and improve her
standing and i think it's fair to say
despite dominic grav getting this deputy
prime minister title he's not
particularly happy i think his team feel
that he has been hard done by and made a
scapegoat on afghanistan
james there's a lot of talk about a sort
of purge of loyalist with uh robert
generic going and robert buckland uh is
that a fair analysis
it is bruce and i think it's also
particularly brutal when you consider
how important robert buckland was to
boris jones in that 2019 leadership
contest you know he was one of the
people who offered kind of reassurance
to the one nation wing of the party uh
about a johnson government uh i think
robert jennerick i think robert generick
is guilty of overly enthusiastically
doing what number 10 asked him to do
number 10 asked him to come up with kind
of radical reforms of the planning
system he did that and tory mps took
fright at the idea and and he is paying
the price for that and i think there is
a
there is always a danger when you are
prime minister but a reshuffle creates
uh more enemies than friends now boris
johnson
already has quite a few enemies on the
back benches um you saw that in the 25
tory mps who rebelled on on overseas aid
just before the summer recess but he has
a majority of 80 and which gives him a
certain installation on this but i think
it is i think this reshuffle shows as
casey was saying but he's not overly
concerned about backbench opinion in his
own party you know um i think a nurse
prime minister might have decided it was
safer to keep gavin williamson in the
tent uh rather than have him outside
boris johnson chose to to sack him
outright rather than send them to leader
of a house or or
or some other role like that
james lastly i'd just like to ask you
about outcast the australian us and uk
security alliance that's been announced
and it's been rather lost in news about
the reshuffle and indeed harry and megan
uh how significant is this
i think this will last much longer than
the consequences than the reshuffle i
think in the history books this will be
regarded as a much more
important moment
i think what it means is that this is a
the special relationship the power of a
special relationship is but it doesn't
actually rely on the relationship
between the president of the day and the
prime minister of the day it is built
around uh institutional levels of
military and intelligence cooperation
what this new deal between the us the uk
and australia does is create another
special relationship you know there are
three people there are three countries
in this in this relationship um uh very
modern uh and you know you've got
and what it
on a military and a technological level
there is a level of cooperation and
interoperability between the us
australia and the uk that will continue
regardless of who is in charge now i
think this also
reflects uh the fact that the indo this
put some reality behind the indo-pacific
tilt the british ministers like to speak
about i think it is although china is
not named in the statement why would you
be cooperating to build a nuclear
submarine and on a whole series of
technologies like artificial
intelligence if your main concern was
not china this is this is clearly
designed to be a new security alliance
aimed at trying to contain china uh in
the in the indo-pacific and i think it
will have huge lasting significance i i
think you know this might well be the
foreign policy legacy of this government
thank you james thank you katie now liz
trust the new foreign secretary might
want to look at what is happening in
rwanda
the author michaela wrong has been
declared an enemy of the state pretty
much by rwandan president paul kagame
here's what he said on tv
last weekend
now this man this woman you you you
talked about
what is it michaela wrong the one who
wrote the book
i mean
by the way
by the time it came out
we had known it was being written
for
about a year or two
and we know those who sponsored her to
do it
both from outside and
others in the neighboring
countries some from far away north
others from here
even the one who wrote the book
was a very close friend
of the one
she sent she centered the book on
this was the source with the most of
these things
yes the
guy who died in south africa then
uh they were close very close personal
friends
and i think
she took
the story pass on it as well and then
[Music]
between the person
she loved and the country
she took the
side of the person
michaela joins me now michaela you start
your fascinating piece this week
by saying that you don't think paul
kagame wants to have you assassinated
but he certainly seems to be out to
trash your reputation can you tell us a
little bit about why
uh well back in april my book do not
disturb came out
and it's a book that is a sort of um
very
strong critique let's put it that way of
president paul kagame and his regime
one of the many issues that focuses on
is
the international
campaign that his um his embassies
usually his high commissions abroad
runs to track down
uh political distance human rights
activists journalists who have stood up
to his regime disagreed with him or set
up opposition parties
and i
launched that investigation because a
man called patrick karagaya had been
killed um strangled in a johannesburg
hotel and he was the head of the former
head of external intelligence for paul
kagame one of his closest friends they'd
been schooled together they had been
young rebels together their families had
known each other all their lives
and
that was a very shocking event
in at the end of 2013
that he had reached out to this man who
had fled into exile set up an opposition
party become very critical of the regime
that he had been a part of um and he had
it
all the evidence indicated that um the
the government of rwanda had had this
man assassinated um so i take that as my
kickoff point in the book and then i
sort of say but this isn't the only
example and i sort of start listing
all the various countries in scandinavia
in north america in europe across africa
as far as australia
where uh the rwandan high commissions
and embassies will be used as hubs and
from there intelligence agents will go
out and try and track down and either
beat up brutalize or intimidate or
sort of intimidate into silence or in
the worst cases assassinate people who
they see as threats to the regime so
obviously they didn't make me many
friends um in kigali but what was really
striking about um what happened on
sunday which was that paul kagame gave a
very very long interview
on rwandan television which was streamed
live and
sort of after about half an hour he
started talking about my book and
instead of addressing these issues of
sort of why is the rohana regime you
know doing this why is it hunting down
these people and silencing them why
doesn't it you know if it's got evidence
that these people
are terrorists as they often will accuse
them being why isn't it presenting that
evidence um uh to foreign governments
asking for them to be extradited why
isn't it going through the usual
judicial processes instead of addressing
those issues this was a just an attack
on me as a person so i was accused of
being in the pay of foreign governments
it was very obvious that he was
referring in one case to uganda which is
his neighbouring country that he has no
love lost for ugandan president yuwari
museveni but he also referred to
governments further north and the idea
was that they had sponsored my book that
was why i'd written it and also he then
suggested that the reason i'd written
the book and why it was such a sort of
strong attack was because i was so close
to patrick karagaia the main protagonist
because we were lovers so i was
listening to this and just sort of
shaking my head and thinking why didn't
you address the issues instead of
attacking me as a person
he also went further and suggested if if
you don't mind me repeating the
suggestion that you're the lover of the
ugandan president muslims um no he he he
hasn't suggested that but that has been
said um on uh the various troll accounts
that are run basically by the government
there are a series i've been the i've
been the sort of target of
of endless hundreds thousands of abusive
um tweets ever since the book came out
and these are these are accounts that
are are controlled social media accounts
controlled by the rwandan intelligence
services the police sometimes the
president's office's office uh waits in
and they they are often camouflaged as
being normal twitter accounts but in
fact
you know it's known that this is this is
what the the sort of the regime this is
how it defends itself it has this very
vitriolic um uh trolling uh activity uh
targeted at people like me so yeah the
suggestion has been made that i was also
the lover of um you're wearing a seventy
um the president of uganda so it seems
that i really get around
well it's a bit of an irony though isn't
it that you are it's being suggested
that you are somehow a kind of a agent
of
western powers of outside powers trying
to shape uganda when the truth is
western powers are very much behind
kagami and have been for some time
and the reason he seems so alarmed by
you
is because you're threatening his
international reputation which has been
very high and very good for so long
yes i mean he's had um a sort of
marvelous sort of glowing reputation and
so has rwanda as a country ever since
the genocide because i think the world
was so appalled by what happened in 1994
in rwanda when between half a million
and a million people were killed um by
the extremist militias and the army of
juvenile happy aramana the outgoing
president the late president
that there was a feeling of huge
international sympathy for his regime
there was also a feeling of huge guilt
because people were very aware that when
the slaughter started up
the un had pulled out troops instead of
reinforcing them which might have
conceivably put an end to the killing
and since then paul kagame has managed
to build up this reputation as being the
sort of donor friendly
development miracle where you know the
indices statistics on maternal health
and primary school education and
vaccinations are amazing that it's a
lesson to other african countries um so
he's really had the full backing of the
west behind him so it is quite
interesting when you listen to this sort
of three-hour interview on sunday and
you hear how much resentment and how
much paranoia he has towards the west
even while being a heavy heavy heavy um
dependent on their aid uh you know that
he's constantly railing that he doesn't
get
you know that these this media and the
west is trying to do rwanda down that
they're trying to humiliate his country
that they can't bear the thought of a
feisty independent-minded african
country but in fact you know they've
been supporting his government
especially america
and and britain has been
very enthusiastically supporting his
government in financial terms
ever since the genocide so it's a very
weird dichotomy
and it's not as you say in the piece
it's not just you uh that's sort of
blowing the whistle on kagami there's
been a sort of rising tide of
uh
people coming out and and proving and
doing journalism to suggest
that uh he is indeed a brutal dictator
and not
um this heroic figure that he's often
portrayed to be
yeah well i like many journalists who um
i was there just after the genocide in
in 1994 in rwanda i reported on the
country and i've been through a long
trajectory of sort of um
getting initially a little bit worried
about various human rights
issues that arose
the the reports one began to read the
stories one heard the anecdotes of the
way in which um the rwandan patriotic
front his rebel movement had behaved um
when it had been invading the country
before seizing power in 94
than the way it it it went into
neighboring democratic republic of congo
and uh you know
you the un has come out with a
devastating report saying you know tens
of thousands of hutu civilians were
killed in congo
and then you know the way in which it
treats its own people so the the way in
which if you're trying to be an
independent journalist in in in rwanda
or you dare to set up an opposition
party or you just voice your views on
youtube as an ordinary citizen
you're going to have a really hard time
and this what you see is this flood of
people
leaving the country
sort of asking for exile going into
uganda going into kenya
fleeing into north america scandinavia
south africa but also what you see are
just ma you know a lot of disappearances
um of arbitrary arrest the sort of
standard accusation to someone who
becomes a little too critical of the
government a rwandan will be that they
are indulging in subversive activities
or terrorist activities they'll also
often if they're a member of the hutu
the majority community they'll be
accused of being genocide deniers or
genocide you know supporters of of the
genocide ideology that's used constantly
as a weapon
so this is the way he he controls the
country and this has been re written
about repeatedly by human rights groups
um and and by journalists and and yet
you know there is the sort of consensus
in in amongst western governments and
donors that this is an extraordinary and
miraculous government that needs to be
encouraged um and i think in my book i
was sort of saying well it's enough is
enough the the signs are too worrying
there's too much information we know too
much to keep um you know um worshiping
this this african model it's it's simply
not what we have been told
and why do you think uh western
governments are so reluctant to see what
what what is emerging is the truth about
kagami and rwanda
well i think nobody ever likes to change
their mind um and admit that they they
were wrong um i think that that that
whole genocide um
hangover that the guilt at the genocide
has really been
used very successfully by defenders of
the of the regime uh there's sort of
been weaponized you know how dare you
you know kagami's line will often be how
dare you criticize us you know where
were you when we were being slaughtered
if he if he has an interview
where people start asking him you know
journalists uh western journalists start
asking him difficult questions they'll
say well where were you you know how
dare you um so i think there's um a
sense of guilt um there's there's this
development you know this this desperate
need that countries that give a lot of
development aid to africa have for
success stories which are few and far
between and in fact are seem to be
coming you know fewer ever fewer um so
there's this sort of like we need to
have an example of where this this works
this this aid paradigm works um but also
more recently um you know we have
very high concerns about the islamic
insurgencies
in various countries you know there's
concern about something going on in
eastern congo and recently we had an
islamic insurgency
in in mozambique and rwanda steps up to
the plate and kagame you know one of his
most successful exports is disciplined
troops um and he um he is ready to send
them he'll send them very quickly
they're very effective they're very good
at what they do so he has sent them to
central african republic to darfur and
just recently over the summer to
mozambique now you know after
afghanistan no one in the west is going
to be sending you know
soldiers to fight islamic insurgents in
in northern mozambique so if kagame is
willing to do it and he does it fast and
effectively well the west will in return
you know turn maybe a blind eye to the
less savoury aspects of his regime
do you not then slightly admire
his ability to uh to conduct real
politic his skill as a statesman on the
world stage
oh yeah no i really admire it i think
he's brilliant at it um i think he
learned early on he was trained in
military intelligence
as a young man i think he learned early
on that perceptions are what matter
and that it's worth spending a lot of
money on
molding the narrative
and he's done it incredibly successfully
and you see this in various ways he's
also very adept at using sports washing
as it's called um so you know he he he
sort of has reached out and you know has
now got a deal with arsenal and that's
about getting this very gleaming
message there's this image of rwanda uh
to the west and so football players for
arsenal will come out you know wearing
their visit rwanda t-shirts when they go
wear shirts when they go playing um
there are very many aspects he he's also
used bicycling uh basketball um
uh he speaks you know in the past um he
has been a regular speaker in davos um
he always makes a good case
he um has built up his capital as a
conference center so a lot of the sort
of big african institutions like the
african development bank or um
or the african union they will have
their meetings in kigali and they all
all the delegates come away amazed you
know at the gleaming skyscrapers and
that the pristine roads the commonwealth
is supposed to have its meeting there
next year um so he's really a very good
marketer of this narrative of this sort
of phoenix from the ashes uh country
that has sort of beaten you know
against all odds has sort of established
itself as how you want a a young african
state to be i'm just sort of in my book
saying there's a very dirty underside to
that sort of you know you lift up the
stone and the maggots are wriggling
underneath
um and especially in
in mozambique what we've seen with this
deployment in mozambique is that the
local community which is a hutu
community
on the whole
um
is is suddenly being targeted and uh
we're seeing um members of the the hutu
community were taken in for questioning
at the uh by the mozambican police no no
obvious reason why we've seen um a
radio journalist who had escaped from a
rwandan prison had fled to mozambique he
was taken in
he was arrested handed over to the ranan
high commission has never been seen
since he hasn't turned up in either
mozambique or rwanda which makes people
extremely worried about him
and then
really really shockingly um earlier this
week we saw
this
leading businessman one of the richest
men in mozambique
revokant karamon jingo
who was shot outside his house
he was ambushed by three cars and shot
dead
right next to his own house in the
suburbs of uh
of maputu um and you know this is you
know this has all happened
since the rwandans made it clear they
were going to be deploying their troops
in in mozambique and uh what people like
me are sort of suggesting is this seems
to be a quid pro quo so president yusi
has said to kagame um you know we'll let
you do what you want to do with this
very large community of hutus who we
know you haven't very good dealings that
you you haven't got
you know very good relations with um
you can do what you do with them and in
exchange you know we're very grateful
for your security deployment which is
going to help us put down this islamic
insurgency um and it's a this is a very
unsavory deal and it's also extremely
worrying because there are hutu
communities which include dissidents in
neighboring countries in malawi in
tanzania in zambia in you know in in
south africa and they're all looking at
what's just happened in mozambique and
thinking oh okay so it seems that you
know uh
this community is now a sitting duck
it's a target for for a one in
intelligence agents fanning out from the
high commission in maputo
well finally mikayla i mean it seems you
suggest again in the piece that the tide
of international opinion is turning
uh against kagami a bit um we're a long
way from the blair clinton
genocide pr days and uh president joe
biden notably did not see kagami
recently
um
is that likely to make him more
dangerous as a dictator as he sort of
becomes aware that he's lost his the
framework of international support that
he had
i think kagame has always been really
adept at moving from one supporter one
sympathetic community to another he's
great at sort of switching horses so
what you saw recently was that um you
know as as it it began to feel as though
the us and uk were in particular having
issues with his human rights record and
that the love just wasn't there um
suddenly you see this incredible trip
you know by french president emmanuel
macron uh to kigali where he does
everything but apologize for france's
complicity in the genocide france of
course had supported the previous
government um so so you know i think
kagami feels he's got a new friend in
the west in the form of of france um but
um i i don't see the issue so much as
you know
who's supporting him affecting his
behavior i think it's more a question of
long longevity that you know he's been
there de facto leader um
for 27 years now that's an awfully long
time and if you look at any of the
regimes anywhere in the world not just
africa the longer the man stays in power
the more
difficult you know the more challenging
his behavior becomes because all of the
people who used to sort of act as checks
and balances who you know the aides who
were sort of counseling him not to do
certain things they've all been
alienated jailed killed in rwanda's case
the various institutions that acted as
checks and balances have been
emasculated
and you just see somebody who realizes
they have nothing to lose and also who's
determined never to leave power because
if he were to leave power he would face
possible prosecutions for many of these
war crimes that were committed under his
watch by his men
um so i think i think people just just
become the behavior becomes ever more
egregious but it's it's just by dint of
the fact that they've been there far far
too long
well i think it's fair to say you're not
going to go to rwanda any time soon uh
is that a fair assumption even though
you don't think your life is under
direct threat i i'm sure i wouldn't get
a visa
i mean i seem to be very high now on
their list of people um you know who
would be png'ed if they were ever to set
foot in in rwanda uh but that's fine
because as far as i can see any any
journalists working in rwanda today and
many of the researchers who write about
rwanda if they are bent on spending time
in rwanda um or they're based in rwanda
it's really impossible for them to to
operate freely um and to express their
views freely when they when they you
know when they're writing up their their
findings so i think you know you have to
make a choice between are you going to
go there and or are you going to say
what you think and you know and i've
made my choice
michaela thank you very much for coming
on to spectator tv and do stay safe
now we're going to talk about insulate
britain which is a group that is copying
the tactics of extinction rebellion on
climate change this week they've been
disrupting the n25 as part of their goal
to decarbonize all british homes by
2030. i'm joined now by tom slater who
is deputy editor of spiked and roger
hallam who is a founder of extinction
rebellion now roger i understand that
you support insulate britain but what
i'd like to know is do you support the
tactic of disrupting the m25
well what i come on to to talk about
today is is the climate crisis and i've
got a question for for tom which is does
he know what global dimming is roger
perhaps you could start by answering my
question since you've come on
well i want tom to answer my question
what's global well hang on we're not
going to get very far if you don't
answer my question first
do you support the tactic of disrupting
i'm asking a simple question about what
we're talking about right we're we're
here to talk about what's going on with
the climate right that's why people are
sitting in the road so let's talk about
the climber no no you're hitting global
demanding at the spectator to talk about
insulate britain and i'd like you to
answer the question
oh okay so here's another question
what's the carbon lag does tom know what
the carbon lag is
i think you're sounding like a pompous
ball so i'm going to go to tom tom in
the spectator this week you said that
you think that extinction rebellion
is more about class warfare than um
anything else can you explain what you
were talking about
yes i mean the question that has often
confronted us after insulate britain's
activities this week as well as
extinction rebellion um is aren't they
alienating people i think that's really
baked in at this point we saw that in
the frustrated delivery drivers and
builders trying to drag people off of
the m25 to get in the way of them doing
their work
but also because ultimately i think
they've discerned the fact that this
movement is not really about
environmentalism it's about pushing a
particular set of politics which is
about immiserating the countries about
making people's lives worse and on the
basis of some deeply apocalyptic
predictions of what is actually going to
happen i mean roger's been throwing some
questions at me there but i'm i'm
wondering whether or not he still
believes that six billion people are
going to die as a result of climate
change a claim that that famous claim
climate denier organization bbc radio
falls more or less could find zero
evidence to support what we're
effectively seeing here is an attempt to
use the science in quote marks often
deep distortions of what is supposed to
be going on in an attempt to try and
batter society into a kind of pre-modern
pre-industrial type of setup which roger
and his middle class art school friends
might be quite comfortable with but if
you're someone who's still struggling to
make a way just something that you don't
see as a positive thing and if anything
you're very irritated by the tactics
that are set out before it so ultimately
whilst i think this presents itself is
deeply rebellious i think it's deeply
reactionary and so far because it's
trying to make people's lives worse
whether it likes to admit that or not
roger
respond to the allegation of your
reactionary please
well i'm glad i'm glad tom's talked
about the six billion figure because
like that actually gets us onto the core
issue doesn't it like i'm a realist
right i also like drove a white van for
uh 20 years just for the record so i'm
hardly middle class but just for the
record global dimming right that's what
happens when
when we stop putting carbon into the
atmosphere the pollution from carbon
drops the earth and according to a
peer-reviewed paper i.e a real-world
description of what's going to happen
it's going to increase
global temperatures by 0.8 the carbon
lag means you can put carbon into the
atmosphere and it takes ten years to
come through according to a
peer-reviewed paper last year that adds
0.8 degrees to global warming the arctic
blue ocean event
does tom want to tell us what the arctic
blue ocean event is
just so you can contribute to the
numbers i'm still waiting for you to
tell us if you've magicked up some
evidence for your six billion claim that
the vast majority of the people on this
planet are going to be wiped out in
short orders relation to climate change
have you found a peer review study for
that yeah
i'm trying to get to that point
i look forward to it
so i'm i'm giving tom the opportunity
since he's a journalist and he's done
research on it to tell us what the
arctic blue ocean event is everyone
knows it in the industry so why doesn't
tom know i'm sure he does
what is it tom please enlighten us i
write fundamentally not about climate
science i write about politics
yeah well i know enough about climate
change
is there any sickness knows enough about
climate change
stuff you come out with is complete
nonsense but please well i'm i'm just
quoting from the real world here right
there's something called science right
that's what like
like realist conservatives are concerned
about or at least they used to be before
they went down sort of post-modernist
rabbit holes right there's a real world
out there i'm a businessman i deal with
the real world if i don't deal with the
real world i'd go bust so let's look at
what the situation is right we just said
global dimming right that produces 0.8
to global average temperature increase
the carbon lag adds 0.8 the arctic blue
ocean event you should know this it's
super basic that's what happens when the
ice melts in the summer in the arctic
everyone knows what it is it's going to
happen by 2030 according to
peer-reviewed papers out last year that
adds 0.4 so what i want tom to do is add
up 0.8 plus 0.8 plus 0.4 what's that
if you want to trade stats on this roger
fundamentally your prospectus and it
says on your website that in order to
bring about the society that you want
you want to ban flying you want to end
fossil fuel fuels next thursday you want
to stop people from engaging in
consumption apart from essential
consumption you're even liking it to a
kind of lockdown type scenario
indefinitely um and fundamentally what
you're talking about is ending
industrial society right and you must
know roger you're an intelligent man
that over the course of the past two
centuries it's industrial society it's
industrialization which has delivered
the vast majority of humanity from the
kind of penury that you and your fever
dreams see coming in the next few years
we've gone from 95
of the world's population living under
two dollars a day to just under 10
and that wasn't down to an extended
period of particularly nice weather it
was
reindustrialized and it was because of
the fact
you don't need to argue with me on that
point everyone knows capitalism has been
most successful mechanism for increasing
global wealth over the last two
centuries right you know the spectator's
been going since 1828 it's been saying
that for 200 years we all agree there's
no disagreement about that
what we're talking about is the fossil
fuel industry has destroyed capitalism
over the last 10 years by locking in the
destruction of the global economy that's
what 20 of the earth being uninhabitable
means
that's what we're talking about if we're
going to be conservative realists well
i'm first of all not a concern
the problem is he can't do the basic
maps he's come on this zoom he doesn't
even know the basic maps of what's going
to be happening according to the
peer-reviewed papers can i can i take it
sorry please let me take him for a bit
because i i don't think we can just sort
of set each other mass challenges and
pretend this isn't an argument i i i
would like to ask can i ask you one more
question i'll just try another question
about the bottom line if i was in the
business meeting and tom said that i'd
i'd say
we're not enough i've been in i've been
in business for 30 years right roger
we're not in a business to know about
business is you don't [ __ ] right
there's a certain thing
called real life
right if we want to look at the climate
crisis we need to look at it with some
conservative realism actually what i'm
saying is 20 percent of the earth's
surface is uninhabitable in the next 20
to 30 years that's the destruction
in the next 10 to 20 years of 200 years
of capitalism that's what the fossil
fuels have done that's what the fossil
fuel companies have done they've
destroyed capitalism right
i was i lived on a farm and i did
farming for 20 years right do you know
what that's like if you have any idea
what it's like to be a farmer tom do you
know how many hours a week you have to
work to be a farmer
60 to 70 hours a week to be a farmer and
do you know what you do on your on your
day off
please enlighten me you sleep
because you're so knackered
right that's what it is do you have any
idea what it's like to be a delivery
driver during the period of extinction
rebellion i was a delivery driver in a
white van for 20 years right so you you
don't need to you don't need to tell me
why
who ended up losing their job as a
result of these protests now the
question of i haven't told you what
happened to me it's interesting right
what happened to me is i worked my
bollocks off i took her i took a
business i had 200 pounds i turned into
a million pound turnover business i was
employing 25 people within three years i
was the biggest vegetable delivery
business in wales and just before 2006
do you know what happened roger you know
what the weather traditions have been in
wales for the last 10 years roger thank
you let me just tell you for a minute
what happened very quickly please
on the 2nd of june it started raining it
rained every day do you know how many
weeks it takes to destroy a crop
if it rains every day tom if you're
doing any research on that
please tell me
four weeks right after a week you can't
get the tractors on the field after four
weeks of continuous rain all your crops
rot do you know how many days
i'm going to stop you there i'm going to
stop you there i think
thank you very much for ruining this
interview
exactly no why why am i ruining the
interview i'm a businessman i'm the sort
of person that supports conservatism
moving mercifully on we are going to
talk about nfts or non-fungible tokens
if you don't know what these are i don't
blame you but they are taking the
digital art world by storm and they're
selling for astronomical sums
i'm joined by colbin bell who is the
founder of the museum of crypto art to
talk about it
colbin i think we should start for um
listeners and viewers who are not aware
of nfts by explaining a little bit about
what they are
what is an nft where did they come from
and what's it all about
yeah absolutely i think it's probably
easiest to
to recognize where it started and then
to consider how it's evolved right this
was a very sub niche
of uh you know the the cryptocurrency
community right and the crypto community
has always been you know perhaps very
playful uh you know powered by memes
um not taking themselves too seriously i
would say but the technology that they
produce is very powerful
right so the earliest stages of the nft
market
was you know the trading of memes the
trading of rare pepes the you know the
ability to begin to play and experiment
on cryptocurrency chains with different
games
and the items that there were
um
[Music]
and you know all trying to put a a
visual language to a very technical
culture
uh
the technology has since you know
proliferated and as we're seeing has is
being adopted by
all sorts of artists corporations
all for the fact that an nft rapper
really can just be anything
yes
so
would you regard it as the the expanding
frontier of
uh crypto world
i would you know i think it's it
certainly is
an unanticipated consequence the
popularity of nfts
and i think what it speaks to most is
how value
on the internet is beginning to be
captured and shared and owned
right in the past
you know the internet was so ephemeral
everything was fleeting it felt like
whether it's you know the timeline of
instagram or the timeline of twitter
everything just kind of falls and
dissolves away
uh with nfts
it has the ability to kind of capture
those cultural moments on the internet
and perhaps like preserve them or
represent them or somebody now is tasked
as any art collector would with
furthering the story of that moment in
time in the context of that piece
what jack says in the piece which i
found very interesting is that because
for me as a sort of an outsider you one
instantly thinks uh of course all this
stuff can be replicated all nft art can
be replicated very easily why is it
valuable
and what jack says is it may in the
future exist in the metaverse so that in
the future you and i will interact
online and in my room
which i have in the future i would have
hanging let's say a painting like i
would in a in a house today and that is
why these digital artworks if they're
artworks
will be considered valuable because
you'll be able to show them off as it
were in
uh the metaverse
i mean that's that's right proper right
it's uh
this is the world that i'm actually
currently living in with the museum
right that was the big innovation is to
come along and build a museum in virtual
reality and begin to put context and use
case to these nfts as artworks and begin
to look back and say that the history is
important here and that there is a
unique art movement happening here and
there is something you know very
powerful happening at the intersection
of art
technology uh creativity and codes
and the pandemic has forced us to be
even increasingly more digital society
so you know what's to what's going to
stop us in five ten years from having
this meeting in vr and us walking
through the museum of crypto art
sculpture garden and looking at the arts
and having you know an avatar that
represents perhaps a more true version
of our identity
this is what i see
when people
you know really start to understand and
appreciate the metaverse
it's the efficiency it's the ability to
you know have unique identity it's the
ability to kind of like
share and own
common public spaces and the artwork
that exists in those spaces
how
do you distinguish between the pure
speculation and the artistic endeavor i
mean because to me again as an outsider
it feels a bit like a gold rush
for something that is coming
uh and it's a it's a naked grab for
money which i mean is not distinct from
artistic purpose and creativity but it's
a different thing do you regard nfts as
art primarily or as a way to get very
rich very quickly
well look you know anybody that that
will chase money here will ultimately
fall flat on their face right if you
don't know what you're doing you're
already done you know and
um this this for me this is and always
has been an art movement right it's
about for the first time in history
there being an open access network on
the internet that allows anybody to
bring their creativity to a marketplace
and there is no gatekeeper no curator
that can stop or prevent them from doing
that
right they get unique individual
self-expression and they can do it suit
anonymously so they don't have to tie
their real identity to it and this is
kind of just like the the kernel of
freedom that leads to truer freer more
pure art
um
without a doubt speculation at the
moment is is running rampant
right and it is it's beyond like a land
grab phase i saw a very similar thing
happened in 2017 with the ico boom it's
just whatever is being released is being
scooped up speculated on people who are
selling for outrageous things are
doubling down into the market it is very
self-fulfilling at the moment
but i know without a doubt that the
artists were here before it was
speculative
always
believed in the reinvention of the you
know creative economic paradigm and they
will stick around going forwards when
this ultimately all you know comes back
to earth
to continue that long-term vision
well a comparison that's often made is
with the dot-com bubble
uh in the early 2000s i guess and the
idea there was everybody knew something
huge was happening
uh and that there was some sort of
major shift
in the way people were thinking about
value and
and the way the internet was going to
interact with the real world but no one
knew who the winners and losers were so
a lot of people put a lot of money
into things that were ultimately a
complete waste of time and proved to be
a complete waste of money but there were
ultimately big winners do you think is
that a fair
parallel 100
100
these are just rapid boom bus cycles
right nothing goes up forever
so
uh you know except in this instance it's
interesting because you're not dealing
with companies you're dealing with art
and artists
right and
right value is in the eye of a beholder
for any of these pieces
so
you know
it all really does remain to be seen who
is going to come along
um and continue to kind of support
certain artists and i having so much
insight can perhaps know which markets
might be fake might be soft which are
being manipulated
i know all the actors i know you know
all kind of like the characters of the
show i imagine
somebody from the outside would find it
just totally inane and and wild and
ridiculous
um and it is still very very wild wild
west crypto
uh
and it seems to me that the wild west is
uh it's a sort of desert of irony
perhaps you could describe it as because
uh nobody quite knows how sincere
anything is nobody quite knows uh
whether anybody actually believes
anything is artistic how much sincerity
is there in this market uh
i can speak for myself that there's a
tremendous amount of sincerity i would
say a lot
like you look at the the catalan banana
tape to the wall right and you have to
ask the parallel question to the
contemporary art world like what does
that piece represent and how does that
reflect to a younger generation of
individuals that are perhaps interested
in what contemporary art and culture is
being defined at at the highest level
and frankly
to me
you know the selling of invisible
statues a banana tape to the wall all of
it is just
totally
pick pick up pick an adjective you know
it's in my mind it's gross
um
all i know that what we're doing here is
native to us there is real
self-expression happening there is
tremendous creative output requiring
hours of input and it speaks more to the
ideals and ideas that i care about than
anything that i've seen from the
traditional contemporary art world
is it in a way
cosmic revenge on the contemporary art
world which is finding it very difficult
to deal with this new i mean some
auction houses are as jack says in his
piece uh christie's sotheby's i believe
bonhams too they are now doing
nft auctions
but there is a resistance uh among the
modern art world because for a long time
they've enjoyed the fruits of the is it
art debate and now the is it art debate
is moving online and i get the
impression a lot of modern artists are
not comfortable with that
you would be absolutely right right like
a lot of dealers a lot of
you know contemporary galleries feel
that perhaps the sands uh slipping
between their fingers of of what they
built and i am i have no revenge
narrative in me
right i'm not here to like spite those
people but i'm just here to do what is
authentic and genuine to me in a
community that i represent
and just identifying that there are
better ways um to do this you know there
would have been zero chance for me to
become a traditional art collector in
new york city going to galleries in
chelsea's trying to ever get a piece off
the wall in this world i have direct
communication to the artists we can
speak on the piece
and you know we make an agreement
between us
and that's that is so much more powerful
and interesting to me than to go through
any sort of middle mana broker
colburn thank you very much for joining
us
that is it for this week's episode thank
you very much for watching if you manage
to make it through the extinction
rebellion section i think you deserve a
prize
and if you would like to watch more
spectator tv please don't forget to
subscribe by clicking the button at the
bottom of the screen and then clicking
the bell icon so you receive that
notification
every time we broadcast an episode
thanks again please join us next week
[Music]
you